all right
you see how far he's gonna go all right
so what i see is
the sand is sometimes here that's not
very much
okay and sometimes this hand is way over
here
now if he moves out of the way please
this is not the inverse bar
so the question was what after i do
the initial uh angle cancellation on the
cross
lateral shoulder what am i doing with
his arm
some of you are
opening it up do you see
then feel feel that
and you feel that which one gives you
back your slack
this this one does you see his watch all
the play in his shoulder
is all okay
so feel how it went dead
okay so let's say you uh try to turn in
do you see the arm's doing that
let's say you try to pull my arm
let's say you try to extend my arm
let's say you try to curl my arm
my arm is in that space
and with it you're
between these two points you're
affecting this mass
between the two points between the two
points
[Music]
so just like when i'm here that's what
moves him
and now i have two points two points are
moving his mouth
this is different different
you have two points of contact two
points of contact
two points of contact working together
two points
take out the slack in his arm
by taking out the slack in your arm and
using it
as two points of control okay
not two unique points
or one than the other point two points
of control
two points so i'll show you my
preference because
i'm not doing that to get his head down
the two points are moving him oh
so i just leave my hand there i
want my hand here as opposed to down
here because i wasn't using it to
cut him so my hands up here so
uh i can strike from here okay
so then he comes up take his balance and
then
it goes here that's when i open the hand
up play with that
see see what he thinks here's my two
points of control
he's going to go oh he lost the script
this is where i can
him okay that's where i am then i open
and open
[Music]
oh
um so let's go
let's go back to the first part of the
test the body okay so
his body look how much he moves okay
i find that important that because
that's going to train your
your ik adhesion it's going to train
your ipd
but leaving them there
[Music]
uh i don't think that translates
into any kind of g
so uh in other words
he's he's doing his stuff you're never
gonna get back here
you're never gonna get back there
the way you tend to get edemi when it's
more freestyle
is he's going i take that pattern right
he's going to turn to adjust i keep
turning this
this is kind of where you get your edema
okay
it's more a combination of either him
going by me all the way
or a combination of me going and him
going so
we're here he's he starts to take that
turn and i move this way
i'm moving but the idea of
getting to the back
doesn't work okay so
might as well do the do the ik adhesion
so
you're moving him from one control point
and then you're going to two like one
control point
back to two control points
so you you're not going to go around so
you can just
right and you're going to move them
[Music]
there you see this badly he doesn't even
want to go that far
he's got to go
here oh move
boom there we go
okay make everyone move through your ik
adhesion
and create the opening to the rim
so wall that's the opening there
that is not an opening he's standing in
between
so warm this way
okay